2021's been quite the eventful year
hasn't it a lot of things have happened
but one thing remained constant relative
to the previous few years we've got our
fair share of overpowered characters so
we're here to talk about them again some
ideas floating around in your head
already well i'm not gonna do a
countdown because i'll be giving notice
to characters who are overpowered in the
context of their own shows it wouldn't
be fair to compare someone from say
attack on titan to someone from re zero
now is it with that brief list spoiler
out the way though let's get on to it
here are who i think are the most
overpowered characters that 2021 has
given us
move over kirito the new age is now i
don't know about you but i feel that
rimaru has become the poster child for
overpowered isakai protagonists now
amidst the bajillions of isakai with
overpowered protagonists that we've had
over the past few years rimaru and slime
just stand out so much more i can also
tell that the adaptation was given much
more love due to how well the fights
that showcase the slime characters metal
are made and that pays off in a big way
in catapulting the show to be one of the
best in the genre well season two of
slime aired earlier this year and it did
more of the same this time pushing
rimaru into complete demon lord status
and making him even stronger if he
thought he was pretty broken in the
first season wait till you see what he
can do now even the final boss of the
season stood little to no chance
haplessly getting pummeled and consumed
by our protagonist enemies beware for i
see rimaru getting even stronger well
for now we do have a movie to look out
for as well don't we the third season
announcement after that
i wish
pandora's exactly who i was thinking
when i first mentioned re zero in the
intro and how could you not this is the
witch of vainglory who was responsible
for emilia's whole backstory and the
incident surrounding the bond of ice ova
granted she didn't come alone but she
just blows regulus out of the water in
terms of being overpowered and we saw
how strong regulus was in the first
episode of season two pandora and goose
never really had a chance even after
they pulled out all the stops to protect
amelia they were light years away from
beating the witch and there's no shame
in that though i mean have you seen what
pandora can do how do you beat being
able to rewrite reality oh she can also
bring herself back to life too
manipulating senses and memories seems
to be the least broken amongst the
things in her arsenal and that's very
telling it begs the question as to how
our protagonists will deal with her in
the future because i'm certain that the
time for confrontation will eventually
come and our heroes better be prepared
[Music]
now for a more muted example we have
mikey in contrast to the two mentioned
series tokyo revenges is more grounded
in reality that's why i didn't want to
do a countdown and compare these
overpowered characters directly but
consider this you don't become the
leader of the dolman for nothing and is
nicknamed invincible mikey for a reason
only the strongest gets to rule the gank
and he does so in dominant fashion he's
got a slew of curb stomp battles as well
i think the awesome i1 was the one anime
fans would quickly associate with this
but even in the manga he barely lost the
step yet he's nowhere as invincible or
broken within his own universe like say
rimaru but his accomplishments really
count for something you don't become the
leader of one of the most notorious
gangs out there without sheer charisma
and fighting skills and mikey is an
example of a character who very clearly
has earned his status
not much more needs to be said about
ishiki you just let the anime show of
the feats do the talking you know the
guy is in trouble when even the powerful
protagonists of the old series fall so
handily to this member of the otsutsuki
clan we all thought that we'd seen it
all in the first naruto series but many
people are convinced that ishiki is by
far the most strongest character in the
entire franchise a lot of comparisons
have been made between him and fellow
clan member garguya but the truth is i
just don't see it if we're comparing
achievements it takes a brand new
all-or-nothing form for naruto to even
have a chance in combat and speaking of
naruto you should watch that barry and
mode fight it's mind-blowing in a good
way and for those of you who haven't
been watching boruto you'll be in for a
big surprise
but hey speaking of overpowered i'd like
to introduce the sponsors of this video
expressvpn it's the premiere vpn service
that will allow you to bypass those
pesky region locks and enjoy shows you
wouldn't normally be able to access
legally i started using expressvpn and i
never looked back want to watch tokyo
avengers on crunchyroll just open up the
app and select the united states server
and bam now you can watch mikey kick and
ass without worrying about any region
locks but wait for my viewers in the us
there's also something for you you can
also use expressvpn for netflix by
switching your location to get more
anime from different countries and it
does all of this without slowing your
internet speeds down whatsoever i can
stream animate with blazing fast speeds
in hd quality and never experience any
buffering with expressvpn you can also
browse the internet with the maximum
security that a vpn can provide that
includes hiding your location and
protecting you against the scourge of
attacks on privacy that are becoming
more and more prevalent as the days go
by and all you have to do is head on to
my description box and follow the
instructions to download expressvpn or
just go to expressvpn.com
vinnie tube with expressvpn see a brand
new internet without limits start your
trial on the number one vpn service now
now here's an overpowered mentor example
for you either then deities rin makes
this list anyone here finish watching
either then deities it's a really
underrated show isn't it i think it's
from the guy who made interspecies
reviewers and you can quickly tell
briefly at the style in the r rating
more importantly however it features an
overpowered character standing at five
feet tall and having lived for over 800
years we have
rin yes rin the sole survivor of the war
800 years ago the strongest and most
brutal mental that hyanto can ever ask
for her powers may seem simple enough
but don't be fooled this sword is one
mighty weapon capable of wreaking havoc
oh and she has all those crazy abilities
too let's see okay super strength super
speed transformation super regeneration
the list just goes on and on it's no
wonder she looks at the current
generation of so weak if anything it's
just that she's too strong
just when you thought our heroes had it
rough we get shigeraki joining the fray
leader of the league of villains and the
successor to all for one shigaraki's
appearance in the my hero academia
series carries with it a lot of
expectations who could this enigma be
one who's supposedly strong and
diabolical enough to succeed the once
mighty villain who ravaged society after
coming from the season with overhaul and
his broken quirk i honestly was eager to
see what mha has in store for us lo and
behold we get someone with a similar but
even more busted version of it how about
the ability to decay things by touch i'm
not just talking about arms and such
taking the whole decay gimmick a step
further shigaraki gains the ability to
do so without the power's general
weakness yep shigeraki's convinced me
he's a worthy successor to all for one
and dare i say an even more dangerous
replacement
we go back to badass mentors in gojo
yeah i know jiu jitsu kaizen is
technically a 2020 show and the first
show of power exhibited by reverse
gagashi here happened a year ago you
know what happened in 2021 though don't
you hollow purple that's what gojo put
on a show in 2020 and he did it again in
2021 and dare i say this is even more
impressive than the previous one overall
gojo really has that cool overpowered
mentor by plastered all over him from
the get-go it's amazing how he manages
to stick with that moniker and not get
relegated into a job or two arcs into
the series a lot of mentor characters
suffer that fate which i would argue
that the series o nanami did not too
long into his debut not for gojo though
he's been kept strong and continually
looks impressive in his spectacular
displays of power i don't want to spoil
too much about the manga but it says
something when the enemy's game plan
revolves around taking him out of the
equation through a seal yep they didn't
even plan to beat him just seal him
[Music]
of course he'll get a mention seven
deadly sins prides itself as a shown in
anime with a whole bunch of overpowered
characters just brawling against each
other amongst that slew of characters
one person stands out as the most
awe-inspiring and overpowered amongst
them all you guessed it
while modern seven deadly sins don't
have the most stellar reputation the one
thing that's remained consistent ever
since its start is just how much of a
special aura esknow exudes he just has
that it factor and what i think
character design plays a large part in
that he has some damn impressive feats
to back it up too take for example his
battle against the demon king where he
managed to go toe-to-toe with the
ultimate demon or maybe when he just
destroys zeldras escondor just continues
to impress
levi's badass and overpowered meanwhile
water is wet thanks to his feats and
innate good looks and charisma levi's
captured the hearts of many aot fans
ever since the first season we've seen
him live up to his nickname of being
humanity's strongest soldier on so many
occasions most notably probably the time
he just destroyed zeke in season three
well what do you know levi's back in
business in attack on titan's final
season in fact he and zeke had a rematch
and levi continues to impress i know
much of the final season has given more
attention to eren as it should be but to
say that the other characters in aot
have been brushed away to the side would
be doing the series of disservice levi
has been a one-man spotlight stealing
squad for three seasons partly thanks to
his coolness and his accomplishments and
i think that had it not been for
isayama's great character writing levite
would have continued to be one in this
fourth season yep you can tell i'm very
very excited about attack on titan's
grand finale right do you think that
these characters represent this year's
gallery of overpowered characters very
well don't forget to go down into the
comment section and let us know what you
think if you enjoyed this video feel
free to check out what my channel has to
offer now if you really enjoyed it
enough to want to support the channel
financially then you can check out my
patreon your contributions will help so
much in my goal to make even more and
even better videos for you in the future
don't forget to check out our sponsors
of this video expressvpn
all you have to do is click the link in
the description box or go to
expressvpn.com
vinnie tube for a three month free trial
thanks for watching and i hope you have
a good day ahead this is vinnie tube
signing off